what did you think about Emily's stylish
new bangs this season and did you know
that shooting for season 3 was the first
time Bruno guerri visited the top of the
Eiffel Tower am I supposed to do it
Lily Collins actually cut her hair into
a fringe in real life which was what
ultimately inspired the beginning of
season three when Emily takes a pair of
scissors to her hair in a manic moment
they're just bangs okay sometimes we
must keep bangs but everything's fine
it's fine costume designer Marilyn
fattusi became inspired when Lily first
sent her a picture of her new do going
on to explain that it reminded her of
the French icons of the 60s how could
they top filming in Versailles at the
end of season two well among a few other
gorgeous locations season 3 actually
brings us to the top of the Eiffel Tower
it was wild and magical to be up there
just with our crew and cast although
Bruno Gordy is from Paris he'd never
actually taken the time to pay a visit
to the tower's top before making this a
pretty special experience for him it's
every time like this because when you're
on the city you don't know the city
according to Lily Collins she especially
loved getting the chance to film the
nighttime scenes at the feta de la music
for episode 2. during this scene Emily
even gets invited on stage to sing
sharing a special moment with Alfie
Lucian lavascount recalls the night as
being magical the real kind of
electricity when you shoot in a
nightstand you'll kind of feel like big
kids having to sleep over this time the
show wasn't only shot out of Paris but
in the French region of Province as well
which is perhaps best known for their
Lavender Fields series Creator Darren
Starr stated that it was an equally
special visit for their French cast and
crew it's so nice to see them appreciate
and visit their own country in a way
that maybe they hadn't experienced it
before if you're ever in Paris you just
have to visit the Louvre season three of
Emily and Perry actually got to film
inside particularly in the musee days
Arts decorative an art and cultural
Museum that the show transformed into
the set for Pierre cadot's fashion
retrospective Darren Starr became
inspired by the location after seeing
the Dior fashion retrospective there in
my wildest dreams I didn't think we'd
ever actually be here for season three
she takes a lot more influence from her
boss Sylvie and vice versa a costume
designer Marilyn fetusi explains they
love hate each other so Sylvia is
dressed with a bit more color and Emily
is using high-waisted and wide trousers
that she didn't have before director
Andrew Fleming has wanted to film in the
musee D'Orsay ever since season one
we're in the musee let's say it's always
been the three of mine to shoot
something in here prior to filming
Fleming said and walk around the museum
by myself when it was closed and pick
where we could shoot what paintings we
could feature how much do you love
Mindy's outfits costume designer Marilyn
fattusi referred to Mindy as one of the
funniest characters that I have to dress
because it's never enough it's glitter
at 10 A.M or 3pm it's all day long
fatusi's favorite season 3 look for
Mindy is the Soraya chalub gown she
wears in episode 8 which fetusi
describes as being dramatic and perfect
for performing is it really gonna be
that easy kami's understated wedding
dress for the season finale wasn't
actually marketed as a wedding dress
costume designer Marilyn fattousi
admitted that choosing the right dress
for Kami was a bit of a challenge
considering you often think of wedding
dresses as being over the top she found
that this dress designed by Jacques
moose offered the perfect amount of
poetry and delicacy for kami's natural
style she may not have been the bride
but all eyes were still on Emily she
wore a gorgeous floral piece from
Italian designer Jam Batista Valley to
kami's wedding costume designer Marilyn
fattousi explained that Emily doesn't
want a bright color for once because she
was not the bride she doesn't want all
the attention on her before going on to
explain that the dress is white
undertones were definitely chosen for a
reason Emily can be seen wearing a lot
more red lipstick this season which
makeup department head oralipayen
explained is meant to represent her
growing confidence as a businesswoman
before going on to add that we use red
lips in France to go out for example
when you have a party at night you want
to put on a red lip and eyeliner I think
it's wonderful it's so inspiring looking
back on the finale with E news Lily
Collins said my reaction was wait what I
had heard rumors of like five different
endings and then realized that it was
actually all five in one episode so we
were very surprised very shocked Lucas
Bravo described it as it's an amazing uh
Cliffhanger while Lucian count
summarized the finale as being
traumatizing messy chaotic the whole
shebang there's so much more I wish I
could tell you making the third season
of Emily and Perry was definitely an
adventure in and of itself between
filming on the top of the Eiffel Tower
to the Lavender Fields of Province we're
dying to know what your favorite
location was this season make sure to
let us know down below